pas de bras pas de chocolat c'est vrai
ou c'est dans le film
[Applaudissements]
alors Abdel allez 19 millions de
spectateurs intouchables le film d'Éric
Toledano et d'Olivier Nakache avec Omar
Sy et François Cluzet et le troisième
plus gros succès de toute l'histoire du
cinéma français se succès est tiré d'une
histoire vraie celle de Philippe pozzodi
Borgo aristocrate Corse chef
d'entreprise et de la vôtre Abdel alors
votre version des faits vous la racontez
dans un livre intitulé tu as changé ma
vie publié chez Michel Lafont on en
reparle à 20h
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes né le 25 avril 1971 à
Alger mais vous avez quatre ans lorsque
vos parents vous donnent vous et votre
frère aîné à votre oncle belle cassette
et à votre tente Amina qui vivent à
Paris et qui ne peuvent pas avoir
d'enfant c'est courant ça de donner des
enfants c'est pas considéré comme donner
c'est considérer un peu comme confié et
dans la culture occidentale on considère
que c'est un abandon ou un don c'est
absolument pas ça puisqu'on est aussi
bien élevé par nos voisins que par nos
oncles nos tantes alors vous découvrez
Paris à l'âge de 4 ans et Amina votre
tente donc est tellement heureuse
d'avoir tout à coup deux fils qu'elle
voulait une totale liberté et là vous
prenez l'habitude allez vous promener
tout seul dans la cité de Beaugrenelle
dans le 15e où vous habitez à ce
moment-là
et votre premier terrain de jeu c'est le
prisonnier des bonbons un jour vous
faites piquer moi je l'avais mal fait
sur là vous vous retrouvez au poste
c'est votre première infraction et ça
sera pas la dernière non c'est le début
d'une longue carrière alors en sortant
du poste en fait vous êtes ravi parce
que vous avez gardé trois oursons en
guimauve il me reste encore de la
marchandise la cam
alors là c'est le début de l'escalade en
fait à l'école la punition la plus
sévère c'est de mettre l'élève à la
porte de la classe lui fait tout pour se
faire expulser parce que quand il est
dans le couloir il peut faire les poches
des manteaux qui sont accrochés au
porte-manteau
on m'offrait ça devant moi il fallait
être fou pour refuser alors le jour de
vos dix ans alors que vous fouillez dans
le duffolcode d'une camarade de classe
vous trouvez une photo de la
propriétaire à moitié nue et là vous la
racquêtez quoi alors jusqu'au jour vous
êtes convoqué quand même pour extorsion
de fonds exact à 10 ans
je sais pas ce que c'était pour moi
c'était une photo un point c'est tout
alors durant l'adolescence vous
multipliez les petits larcins avec vos
copains de beaux Grenelle et vous vous
retrouvez régulièrement en garde à vue à
14 ans vous êtes orienté vers une
filière mécanique dans un lycée
professionnel et vous n'y allez pas en
fait ça prenait trop de temps et ça
rapportait rien c'était pas amusant en
plus alors la nuit vous fourguer ce que
vous avez volé au tourisme dans la
journée les appareils photos des
caméscopes des Walkman travailler plus
pour gagner plus je travaillais de jour
et je vendais de nuit qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je fasse de plus
mais à l'âge de 18 ans vous retrouvez
pour la première fois devant un juge
vous écopez de 18 mois de tôle dont 10
ferme vous dites que quand vous arrivez
en prison en fait ça vous ça vous
soulage dans le Club Med c'était pas
aussi difficile que ça c'est pas les
coûts de la savonnette si ça se dit
c'est rien d'aussi effarant quoi
à peine sorti de Fleury-Mérogis vous y
retournez voilà quand même ça devient un
peu grave quoi voilà j'ai perdu un peu
de temps quoi là vous vous dites il faut
quand même que je fasse quelque chose de
sérieux vous devenez livreur de pizza et
là vous êtes un employé modèle et vous
finirez même par avoir une boutique en
gérance j'étais le meilleur c'est normal
sauf que vous arnaquez la direction en
vendant des pizzas que vous déclarez pas
quoi c'était plus rentable
jusqu'au jour où la direction décide
d'équiper les magasins d'ordinateurs ils
savaient exactement ce que j'avais en
caisse avant même que je l'ai contre
même si j'avais même plus besoin de
savoir compter quoi et là vous inscrivez
à l'ANPE vous dites deux ans
sans rien [__] quoi c'est là que
commence le film intouchable au moment
où vous allez faire des rendez-vous pour
faire signer des papiers pour la NPE
juste pour prouver que vous cherchez du
travail en fait voilà exactement et un
jour vous recevez une convocation pour
un job dans le 16e arrondissement vous y
allez donc juste pour faire signer la
convocation et là vous refusez
d'attendre avec les autres candidats ça
servait à rien que j'attendais j'étais
pas venu pour bosser j'aurais jamais eu
l'impression qu'il m'aurait accepté de
toute façon c'était c'était vraiment un
intouchable pour moi et là pour jeudi
Borgo vous explique le job c'est
d'ailleurs il a besoin de quelqu'un
parce qu'il était traplégique et pour
s'occuper de lui toute la journée quoi
oui mais cela faut regarder un peu les
avantages j'étais peut-être délinquant
mais j'étais pas menteur je lui annoncé
la couleur
il a appris il a pris alors il vous
propose un essai qui va durer 10 ans
très rentable pour lui comme pour moi
j'ai bien rigolé en tout cas alors la
première vanne c'est lui qui la sort il
vous dit si on est en retard pour le
déjeuner on rentrera en courant et c'est
vrai qu'à partir de là l'humour devient
votre moyen de communication quoi le
seul point commun qu'on avait c'était
l'humour il y avait rien d'autre de
toute façon pas de bras pas de chocolat
c'est vrai ou c'est dans le film ça
c'est dans le film dans le film la tête
un petit peu amélioré comme je suis pas
aussi bon que dans le film par exemple
vous découvrez que le corps d'un
tétraplégique peut avoir de l'eau
bouillante par exemple sur lui mais ça
ça c'est pas dans la réalité ça c'est
dans l'arrêter on le faisait même avec
la douche c'était pas avec la théière
c'était pas du style à avoir sa petite
tasse de théière à 17h quoi quand vous
arrivez dans sa vie Philippe pozzou di
Borgo est encore en couple et là il va
perdre sa femme d'un cancer et il va
tomber dans la dépression il avait déjà
perdu ses jambes il a payé il perd sa
femme sabe qui reste plus rien
quand même vous n'avez connu sa femme
très sympathique super
trop sérieuse peut-être et c'était pas
c'était pas la grande bourgeoise qui
voulait faire voir qu'elle était
bourgeoise c'était vraiment d'une
simplicité incroyable alors là vous lui
faites découvrir les pétards
j'ai réussi à le mettre superfusion au
joint et à la bouteille mais pas trop la
bouteille mais plus au joint ça a marché
et vous lui dites un truc qui marche
pour se sentir bien mais qui est pas
disponible en pharmacie
qui ouais mais un jour ça viendra
peut-être alors vous amenez des filles
et effectivement le cocktail pétard
fille lui fait du bien quoi c'est la
perte de l'âme Alco les femmes qu'est-ce
que vous voulez de plus je vais gagner
et la scène dans le film elle était
comme ça a complètement ah non c'était
vraiment réel il y avait les pétards il
y avait c'était des copines c'était pas
des filles donc c'était pas des c'était
pas du métier c'était ton apprentissage
aussi voilà alors vous le convainquez
également de remplacer ce le fourgon
équipé dans le monde charge spéciale
tétraplégique qu'on appelait la
bétaillère par une Jaguar XJS 6 tableau
de bord en ronce de noyer ça on le voit
pas dans le film et vous l'avez planté
la caisse j'en ai planté deux la
Rolls-Royce ça là aussi ça c'est la
troisième j'apprenais à conduire à cette
époque là alors extraordinaire ça c'est
vraiment passé comme ça si ça vous
foncez ensemble la nuit tous les deux
complètement ouais mais j'avais plus
rien à perdre j'avais déjà plus de
permis à l'époque et alors là quand vous
faites arrêter il mime des crises
d'épilepsie qui fait que les flics
savent plus quoi dire et vous escorte
jusqu'à l'hôpital de Garges quoi et ça
c'est comme on le voit dans le film
c'est exactement la même manière mais
simplement ça c'est pas fait qu'une
seule fois mais il y avait pas de Paris
à l'époque il y avait pas les 100 francs
ou les 100 euros ce que le film raconte
pas effectivement c'est que vous
utilisez la Jaguar pour les draguer la
nuit quand même j'ai fait avec les
moyens du bord vous savez un petit Shrek
qui se déplace en vélo il a aucune
chance maintenant on a beau être Dracula
en Jaguar j'accepte tout hein que la
voiture
aujourd'hui vous êtes marié exact vous
avez trois enfants faut pas le dire il
vous a aidé à monter votre élevage de
poulet en Algérie exact vous avez
retrouvé vos vrais parents vous êtes
heureux là-bas
je suis heureux de vivre tout court ça
aurait pu être la base ça aurait pu être
ailleurs j'aurais préféré peut-être le
Sénégal ou un autre pays pourquoi pas et
Philippe lui vit au Maroc il a rencontré
une femme il s'appelle Khadija il a
adopté deux petites filles et vous vous
voyez tous les deux on continue à se
voir on a un peu comme les deux petits
vieux démo pécho de temps en temps quand
on se voit on se raconte un peu le passé
oui tous les combien
en moyenne toutes les trois semaines
quatre semaines il y a quand même la
distance je travaille maintenant vous
vous rendez compte que le monde entier
va voir votre histoire je me rends
compte surtout que ça valait le coup de
vivre ma vie quoi fais que ça marche
même encore et du Sud c'est incroyable
je sais pas ce qu'ils arrivent à
comprendre mais parce que c'est
universel justement votre histoire c'est
ça qui est beau vous dites on n'était
pas fait pour s'entendre on a fini par
s'aimer
exact mais c'est pas le
on sait même plus ce que c'est c'est pas
s'aimer c'est pas de l'amitié on sait
plus ce que c'est en fait ça a duré
j'espère que ça continuera du rire alors
vous touchez pas un centime sur le film
mais vous avez demandé tous les deux
qu'une partie des bénéfices soit reversé
à une association qui s'appelle Simon de
sirène qui permet aux handicapés de
vivre dans des maisons adaptées ah c'est
bien vous êtes le premier à le préciser
en général ils se disent tout ce que je
fais énormément de trucs avec mais oui
c'était l'une des conditions qui a été
faite et c'est aussi je crois de mémoire
la première fois qu'un cinéma reverse à
une association aussi directement sans
vouloir jouer sur les mots genre on
donne un euro et on dit qu'on a donné
quoi là ils ont réellement Patrice c'est
fabuleux non ce que je trouve formidable
je sois dans le monde entier le regard
porté sur les handicapés à changer en
quoi deux trois mois tout à fait
à la télévision bien institutionnelle
etc c'est extraordinaire moi ce que je
trouve de ce qui est super dans ce film
c'est que ce n'est pas qu'un film c'est
aussi une réalité à côté qu'on oublie
mais que là le plus intéressant c'est
qu'on sait que c'est une histoire vraie
donc j'ai pas besoin de raconter quelque
chose à la rigole à raconter je m'en
fous complètement je sais que je l'ai
vécu je sais que j'ai bien rigolé ça
serait un refrain j'aurais fait plus bon
moi je l'ai
je l'ai découvert aussi comme tout le
monde il y a une différence quand même
entre vous et le personnage de Marcy
c'est que vous êtes quand même un petit
un petit voyou au départ un petit un
petit marlou quoi je suis sûr que si
Omar écrivait seulement il aurait fait
mieux que moi
on a tous un petit élément pour
nous-mêmes
en tous les cas merci de votre
témoignage alors il y a le DVD
intouchable qui vient de sortir chez TF1
Vidéo merci beaucoup en tous les cases
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu